-Next guest tonight
is a talented actress
you know from shows
such as "8 Simple Rules"
and "The Big Bang Theory."
She both stars in
and executive-produces
the limited series
"The Flight Attendant,"
which premiers on HBO Max
on November 26th.
Let's take a look.
-Where are you?
-Uh, uh, I don't --
This -- This place is so pretty.
-Yeah?
No, okay, that's not an answer
Let's see.
Bangkok.
Oh, speaking of getting arrested
in foreign countries,
do not get arrested there.
The laws are, like, Byzantine.
-Right. Uh, yeah.
How did you --
How did you know
that I'm in Bangkok?
-Oh, when we took that girls
trip to Tuolumne,
and we turned on side something,
'cause, like, kidnapping.
And, um, yeah, you just neve
turned yours off, so...
Listen, you're not, like,
actually in trouble
or something, are you?
-No, I'm, uh...
hung over in Thailand.
-Please welcome back to the show
Kaley Cuoco.
Hi, Kaley!
-Hey, Seth! [ Chuckles ]
-It's so nice to see you.
I'm really excited
about this show.
I watched the first episode.
It's great.
But I do -- I want to ask --
I know you've been spendin
a lot of time quarantining
How has life in isolation
been for you?
-You know what?
I think, like everybody else
mine is surrounded by a lot of
dogs and a lot of alcohol.
So it's been okay.
-Uh-huh.
-You know? But, yeah, we'r
just hanging in there.
I feel like I've quarantined
multiple times.
I've been in multiple places
over the past few months.
And I've really given my all
in quarantine, let me tell you
I've been committed.
-Well, society --
On behalf of society,
I thank you for doing that
You mentioned dogs.
You adopted a dog recently
Dumpy.
Here's Dumpy for everybody
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
That is Sir Dump Truck.
I got him over the first
quarantine, many months ago.
He was supposed to be a foster
and I turned into a foster fail.
I turned into a girl
with a dog in a stroller,
which I really didn't want
to become.
-And it should be noted,
the stroller
is not just stationary
as it is in the photo.
Here's a quick video of Dump
doing his thing
in a moving stroller.
-No.
[ Dumpy barks ]
Oh. You're really ferociou
in this stroller.
[ Laughs ]
That dog could kick your ass
-So, Kaley, tell us how...
You know, obviously,
you mentioned
you didn't want to turn into
that girl, and now here you are.
Do you notice -- Do you watch it
happening in real time,
as you slowly realize
"I am now a person
who has a dog in a stroller?
-I didn't want
to be that person.
You know, we have multiple dogs,
none of which have strollers
But I was in New York
for so long, shooting.
And Dumpy was there,
and he's older,
so I thought it would be easie
to get out and get around --
right? -- in the stroller.
And the funny part is,
he's a very scared dog.
He had a very traumatic life
before me.
In the stroller, he has
this bravery and self-assuranc
that I've never --
As you can see, he barks.
He becomes completely aggressive
in the stroller.
I don't know
what comes over in his brain
-Uh, well, you know what?
We gotta let Dumpy
live his best life.
He has some paparazzi,
as well, yes?
People are excited to see Dump
on the streets.
-Oh, my God. I'm telling you
So, we were in --
I was living in Tribeca,
which is a very -- you know,
it's pretty bougie.
And there are a lot celebs
around and papar--
not -- just a lot of paparazzi
And I realized,
every time I'd come down
early in the morning
to take Dumpy out
to the bathroom,
there was paparazzi.
And I'm thinking, "Oh, my God.
oh, they just
won't leave me alone."
Well, an article that came out
a few days later,
that my girlfriend sent me
and it said,
"Dump Truck goes to the bathroom
with blonde owner."
Had nothing to do with me.
[ Laughs ]
They were there to see the Dumpy
in the stroller.
-You know that means you have to
get a T-shirt
that says "Blonde Owner," right?
-"Blonde Owner." [ Laughs
-You gotta do it.
You gotta make it easy for them.
-Yeah, no one cared it was me.
They followed --
They were following us
all over New York.
And I realized they were tryin
to get all of the photos
of Dumpy in the stroller.
He became an overnight success
-Hopefully --
Please do not allow your
personal jealousy towards that
to drive a wedge
between you and Dumpy.
I'm begging that of you.
-I was pretty pissed.
Let me tell you.
The narcissist inside me
thought everyone
wanted to see me,
but I was sorely mistaken.
[ Chuckles ]
-So, congrats on the show.
It's weird to say
this show is fun,
because -- spoiler alert -
some very dark things happen
But, tonally, it is --
I don't know.
There's a nice energy to it.
I assume getting the tone righ
was a massive part of the show
that you're also a producer on
-I gotta tell you, the amount of
conversations we had
about the word "tone"--
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
-Over the last year,
it's pretty --
I didn't think I could say
that word so many times
or hear other people say
that word so many times.
I wish I had picked
a clearer tone of a projec
for my first producing venture
but I picked a tricky one.
And, yes, it's definitely --
it rides a wave
of adventure and sadness.
And, obviously,
there's a brutal murder.
But since I can't help but b
a little funny here and there,
it was definitely written
in my voice.
-Yes, based on
the episode I've seen,
you thread the needle
very nicely.
And you also had to work around,
like a lot of productions,
the pandemic
we're living through.
You, sort of, got in
just under the wire,
because you were shooting
in Italy, right?
-We were shooting in Italy, yes.
We shot in Thailand and Italy.
And then, in Italy, was
in end of January,
right before
things started shutting down
So, and then, also, we had
all these months off,
like everybody else.
And then we just went back
and finished,
which was also hilarious,
because the show takes place
in winter in New York.
And we went back, and
it was beautiful and summer.
And everyone in the background
was wearing masks.
So it was a very strange trip.
When we looked at dailies, w
were like, "Oh, my God.
That guy's got a mask on."
And we're trying to, like, shift
how we were doing everything
-And you have -- I think
a lot of productions
have rules now about the numbe
of extras you can have.
And you have to double up
and use people more than once.
That must make things tricky
as well.
-We... [ Laughs ] So, yes.
So, we obviously were trying
to minimize any new people
in and out of our set.
So we had six extras
that we used for 2 1/2 months.
And we kept putting them
in different wigs,
different outfits,
kind of mixing
and matching them.
On the plane, too,
because we had to have the
enter the plane.
I was like, "These people ar
gonna look like they take
a lot of flights,
if anyone notices."
But it was the only way
we could do it.
So we -- we did our best.
-You should do another show,
just about these
six weird people
that are constantly going
back and forth
from New York to Thailand.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-It would be funny.
-It's looking very creepy.
It's very strange.
But I could --
When I would watch dailies
I'm like, "Oh, my God.
You guys, we had those two
people talk to each other
in the last scene.
We gotta move them around.
-[ Laughs ]
Well, it all worked out.
And now, we have, coming up,
Thanksgiving,
which I think is going to be
obviously, tricky
and different for everybod
this year.
You also have a birthday
coming up.
Do you have any plans?
Are you gonna --
Is it just gonna be
you and Dumpy
scrolling through "Daily Mail"
to see if
your pictures are in there
-I'm having a party
for like 200 people
on my birthday.
-Oh, God.
-I'm really excited about it
-Hopefully, just 200 peopl
who know a lot of --
have a lot of elderly friends.
I think that's best.
-Oh, exactly.
That's what I was thinking
Yeah, for sure. for sure.
-Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
Thank you for all your tim
in quarantine.
We do appreciate
everybody taking it seriously.
Love to Dumpy.
We are hoping
you can help us book him.
And all the best, Kaley.
-I didn't want that to happen.
Thank you.
[ Both laugh ]
-Be well.
The first three episodes of "The
Flight Attendant"
will be available on HBO Max
on Thanksgiving Day.
A great way to spend some time